en dialyse bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors joe biden a donc
remporté le mini fusées quatre états sur
six comment expliquer le retour presque
inattendu de l'ancien vice président
américain
je dirais que c'était un travail parmi
les démocrates pour rassembler les
morceaux d'une course à la primaire qui
étaient dispersés depuis les débuts
qu'est ce qu'on a vu on a vu un candidat
de la gauche radicale
on a vu monsieur bart hayden qui a eu du
mal à lancer sa campagne au début on a
vu un républicain qui devenu démocrate
un milliardaire pour soutenir la
position de démocrates
on a vu plusieurs personnes qui se dé
monde divisé au sein de la parti
démocrate dont on efface un quasi
effondrement de la parti démocrate qui
aujourd'hui fait ce qu'il peut pour
rassembler tout le monde derrière leur
candidat qui était il ya deux semaines
en quatrième position
donc aujourd'hui il essaie faire le
maximum derrière leur candidat et quand
même il appelle alors candidat de
monsieur ban à 110 dsc et fonderies
tremblements pourquoi parce que ils
veulent ces réunions contre une personne
monsieur trump 5 en pagne contre le
président d'europe et c'est par une
compagne pour l'amérique c'est un
campagne contre une personne donc il ya
là la faiblesse des la course des
démocrates alors vous venez de le
mentionner un cette main tendue de joe
biden vers bernie sanders pour battre je
cite ensemble donald trump battre donald
trump justement novembre prochain est ce
que vous pensez que les deux mots kraton
des chances de le faire
pas du tout je pense qu'il est important
de constater pas c'est très peu a
diffusé dans les médias
il y avait aussi les premiers à michigan
côté républicain et vous regardez bien
lors des primaires pour la réélection de
monsieur obama en 2012 dans l'état du
michigan qui est un état clé parmi les
démocrates
monsieur tron a peu à voir 10% des plus
des votes qui mme obama
donc ce que vous remarquez c'est que
monsieur 30 d'avancé candidat dans le
résultat au niveau des primaires sa
performance au niveau des courses est
largement en avance par rapport aux
démocrates
et je pense que les candidats n'ont pas
de programme contre troy ni pour
l'amérique
ils ont un programme contre une personne
d'un autre homme donc ce n'est pas un
programme pour aider l'amérique
c'est un programme pour défendre leur
idéologie et vu qu'il ya main tendue
vers bernie sanders
on peut imaginer qu'il est modérée sont
prêts à sacrifier une partie de leur
programme vers un socialisme radical
vous venez de parler de l'état du
michigan le michigan avait créé la
surprise effectivement en 2016 puisque
c'est un état d'habitude démocrates les
républicains avaient gagné
donald trump s'était imposé face à
hillary clinton y est ce que voilà en
novembre prochain on pourrait assister
un nouveau revirement de situation dans
cet état qui reste quand même un des
plus importants des états unis à cause
de son côté industriel ce que vous
pouvez constater
parmi les défenses et art où il ya un
bassin industriel très important c'est
que monsieur donald trump a pu ramener
l'emploi à ses états est ce qu'on
constate c'est son succès au niveau de
la baisse du chômage a fait en sorte
qu'ils aient toutes les électeurs vont
voter pour monsieur trompe et que ce
sera le même phénomène américaines qui
ont d'autres états et nous imaginons
qu'il y aura pas d'autre possibilité que
pour la réélection de monsieur trompe
dans l'état du michigan et vous verrez
que ça va être partout de la même
manière alors dans le contexte
international dans lequel nous sommes
avec la crise du du coronavirus on sait
qu'elle s'est invitée justement pour la
première fois dans cette campagne
démocrate certains meetings ont été
annulés par joe biden et bernie sanders
on parle beaucoup de la gestion de
donald trump 1 face à hawk ovi de 19
est-ce que la gestion de cette crise
pourrait affecter la suite de de cette
course à l'investiture et plus largement
les élections en novembre à votre avis
voilà par rapport à la crise avec le
chrono virus il faut comprendre que
c'est un crise bien entendu l'amérique
devait être avec son président monsieur
trombe et reste positive et il doit
rassurer son peuple il fait ce qu'il
doit faire pour aider l'amérique comme
au moment des guerres
il faut que tous les américains soient
réunir derrière le président aujourd'hui
ce que je crains c'est que les
démocrates dont cette année des courses
à la réélection vont utiliser cette
crise des couronnes virus pour essayer
de séparer les amériques et faire un
guerre contre la personne de monsieur
trompe je pense qu'ils aient je rappelle
qu'il est nécessaire que les américains
restent unis suite
et face à ces crises notre président a
déjà pu faire baisser le chômage
personne n'a imaginé il ya deux ans
qu'ils retrouvent le faire tout le monde
était surpris par les résultats
il faudra lui faire confiance dans la
gestion de cette crise et l'ess et lui
faire ce qu'il doit faire
bilan tendu y aura des décisions
difficiles qui seront prises dans les
semaines à venir
et bien entendu et ce ne sera pas une
situation facile à gérer donc et y aura
bien entendu y aura messieurs by dane et
messieurs centers qui vont continuer à
critiquer notre président et dont on ne
sait pas si de leur côté ils sont lents
tongs adversaires au lieu dé renforcer
l'esprit du peuple et qu'ils soient tous
derrière leur président je pense que les
résultats c'est ce qui compte
qui compte parmi nous et vous devrez
savoir que monsieur tron a toujours été
là et donc aujourd'hui on va être la
face à une situation qui sera géré par
lui et dans les mois qui vont suivre y
aura quand même une bonne gestion
aurélien pas imaginer qu'ils avec des
mesures qui seront prises qui est tout
de suite vous verrez le résultat
merci et bien en tout cas merci beaucoup
grandi à luz d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat franco américain et président des
républicains
miss france